[Applause]
this is the new MacBook Air the new iPad
pro hello from Brooklyn where Apple just
announced some new computers and yes
they held their event in Brooklyn not in
Cupertino today so two types of
computers they really talked about today
the iPad and the Mac on the iPad we saw
a completely redesigned iPad pro there
are two new sizes now an 11 inch and a
12 point 9 inch and unlike the old iPad
pro and a lot like the new iPhones
there's no home button no touch ID
instead now you've got face ID so it
looks like a really seamless display and
with these new iPad pros the
second-generation pencil has been
completely redesigned other than the new
screens it's got a new pencil and that
clicks to the top of it and it charges
that way it's pretty cool and it has a
new keyboard cover which which supports
two angles to prop up the screen overall
the iPad pros just seemed a lot nicer
and seemed a lot more capable and also
have faster processors and they're
talking a lot more about full full
screen apps that can run on these and
really you could that can handle a lot
more of your computing workload they are
more expensive than the previous iPad
pros the smaller one starts at $7.99 and
the bigger one $9.99 and that doesn't
include the keyboard or the pencil it's
time for a new MacBook Air there was
good news for Mac lovers or macbook
lovers they revived the MacBook Air with
a new design and a new Retina screen
every part of the product has been
redesigned and re-engineered is this
something lots of us have wanted Apple
to do for years look at the lower end of
the MacBook lineup and really bring some
of the more premium features to it so as
a Retina screen to USB C ports and a
keyboard that's very similar to the
MacBook Pro line something we saw today
was Apple raising the price of all of
the devices the iPad pro used to start
at six hundred and forty nine dollars
now it starts at seven hundred and
ninety nine dollars the MacBook Air
started a thousand dollars and now it's
at twelve hundred dollars and this just
follows what Apple has been doing across
its lineup
on the iPhones upping the price of the
devices because people are not upgrading
as frequently
[Music]